hello everybody i'm alex templeton
i work with the eastern new energy
project and we are a
project that's been set up to
help organizations decarbonize
in various shapes and forms
yeah sure so
i'm james allenwood i'm
working with alexis
and we're helping
businesses organizations community
groups and parishes to decarbonize so
we're looking
today to talk to you about
the kind of things that we can offer
underneath the new energy project but
we're also really keen to hear from you
about what kind of challenges you're
facing so that we can try and tailor
some of our services to overcome some of
those barriers
right that's right so um
so i'll just talk so just talk a bit
about how this project came across and
basically
once we've talked about how the project
came into being
and uh what we think we might do
basically we want to make it an open
discussion i want to hear from you what
your challenges are and what you want
so
so as part of part of our wider work so
we're the project is looking at rapid
detailation
helping organizations decarbonize um
quickly efficiently cost effectively
um
as part of our work we wound up talking
with a number of parishes
and there was a common theme started
diverging it's one that parishes
actually have because of their local
connectivity and a local knowledge they
could be really useful
or they could play a big part in
decarbonisation they could be
capitalists in their local area
but it also became clear that they were
disconnected from their districts and
their counties and their combined
authorities
and there was a quite a lot of support
out there but a lot of it was a bit
confusing the disorganized stock staff
and um
and they do
or in our conversations that you didn't
have the right tools that you needed
so
um and there were some common themes
emerging as well as there were struggles
with large solar developers who wanted
to bring um great big projects and
sponsor them down close to villages and
then give the village a little bit of
money and it was
there wasn't much negotiation it was the
same with housing developers
so
what working
i suppose what our job
or what we've been asked to do is
is come and talk with you
and tell us some of the things that we
can do for you and some of the things
that we might do together and the things
that we can do for you
is we can do
if you have a discreet project for
example a
a village hall that you want to put out
a sort of solar on an electric charging
point or you have a school that you're
responsible for we can help you with
feasibility studies we can help you look
for funding we can help you do um
we can help you with a variety of things
it's absolutely up to you to say so
technical feasibility for you we can do
that for specific projects
i think
the more interesting thing that we
wanted to do was
was gather a group of parishes together
maybe sort of five to ten and then work
together with you
to work through your challenges and your
problems and help design the sort of
support that you think that you need
to to sort of develop a net zero action
plan
and to deliver that plan so that that's
the bit i think we're really more
interested in we've had brief
discussions with the national
association of local councils and the
county council about that so there's
there's a lot of support for that idea
if we can collectively develop design
what you need
part of it we can do within our project
and the parts that we can't do within
our project
we can
work as a team to go get additional
funding to develop this and pilot it
and i suppose um
from the conversations with the parishes
we've had so far there's a number of
themes that are emerged in terms of the
sort of things that you might need one
is data where do you get the data to
to help you take a decision i know that
there are certain sorts of data that are
available to parishes through
subscription services but what more
information do you need around carbon
around tree planting around helping
farmers capture carbon through changing
their farming practices
through sort of where the natural grid
is or where the local grid is and
where projects might go that might
easily plug into to those grids so
there's there's a data and information
challenge and you need better data so
you can make plans and take action
a second theme that emerged was was
a lot of parishes wanted more
information on
carbon it's a carbon literacy thing like
how energy and carbon interacts how
you might better use that knowledge to
sort of
plan and deliver that zero action plans
support with shaping neighborhood plans
how do you get a neighborhood plan so it
enables net zero um delivery
um engaging with stakeholders a lot of
the stakeholders got different needs a
business has a different need to a farm
has a different need to a school and
then who are the people coming in doing
the development how do you engage with
housing developers how do you engage
with solid developers or other
developers so that was another theme
and a number of parishes especially down
in cornwall where we've done quite a lot
of pilot work is a lot of parishes down
there
cornwall is a very independent-minded
place they want to start taking control
of their own solar and housing
developments so instead of
facilitating the planning of solar
development they want to do their own
solar development so that's creating
community assets creating community
wealth so the wealth generated by the
housing and energy projects stays within
the community
finance
net zero is going to cost
a we're talking about
renewing
or or editing every bit of
infrastructure that we do over the next
30 years and about half of that has to
happen in the next eight and a half
years if we're going to stay on track
with a 1.5 degree target
so there's an awful lot of money that we
need and i know many parishes have got
access to the public loan board there's
going to be a lot more money and that
needs to be need to work or in our view
it makes sense to work with districts
and counties and local authority pension
funds and try sort of
developing funnels so that money can
much more easily get from where it is
now
to where it needs to be to deliver these
projects
another another key theme
in discussions is capturing carbon using
nature-based solutions so it's it's tree
planting it's helping farmers farm
differently to capture carbon and soil
it's um peat bog restoration salt marsh
reclamation and other more interesting
and unusual ways of
using nature to capture and store karma
and
the the final thing is is who's doing
what where there are many parishes many
community groups who's got a great idea
who's already doing it and how can we
can we copy it instead of just happening
in some happening in some parishions in
hospital why company will know about it
so those are the key themes that are
emerging
um
the other
because of our project is funded by um
prdf european regional development fund
we can only help parish
if it is if it has a business entity
so
if you have a an sme or a social
enterprise or a charity that's easy for
us to work with if not it's quite easy
we've worked with other parishes where
we've helped them set up charities or
social enterprises in order to deliver
things so there's a management
eligibility question
to receive the support i think that's
the main bit about
what
and this is just our first thinking from
our initial conversations the most
important thing
is for to hear from you and to
say what your challenges are
what you want and can we help you
get some of that
that's it i just throw it open to the
floor and say
who wants to say something about the
challenges that you've got or what you
might need
all right yeah and uh from um
council
i think you sort of touched on this
briefly but for me and one big thing is
i think we need a one-stop shop because
we've got yourselves here we've heard
from the community rural energy set up
and as far as i can make out every
parish is reinventing the wheel yes and
it's such a waste of time and energy and
i think that needs to stop if we're
going to make any decent progress in
this
so they are part of our
so so the um rural community energy fund
and community energy staff they're part
of our team right well that's good so
but but no you're you're absolutely
right i mean reinventing the wheel is is
it drives me mad and it happens
everywhere yes and it happens in every
business
every charity and every organization in
the country is sat there thinking how do
we do this
and they're all thinking the same
thoughts and having the same barriers
and
simplifying things and the one-stop shop
is you say
we do need to get much closer to that
but that's part of
what we hope to be able to do and we
will we're not going to if there's
already a service that exists elsewhere
we're not going to redesign it we'll
just bring it to you and say does this
meet your needs and if so how might we
if it doesn't how much or does it nearly
meet your needs how might we change it
so it does it's a bit of design or more
data in a platform whatever it is
so
we're here to do to
find hacks shortcuts move fast if we if
we're going to do a 45 carbon reduction
in eight and a half years we can't spend
another two three years designing and
thinking
we've got to find things that work in
three months
so in some ways eastern ung
sort of takes that role of the
one-stop-shop solution in them we will
try and find those solutions for you and
point you to solutions that already
exist or as alice said
look for ways to improve those solutions
to me meet your needs again if it
doesn't already
so we came to you as a parish and said
like we've got this plan this is what we
want to do
you'd say that's marvelous this is
everything you need that we are aware of
that can help you and visit your
contacts
to save me spending two months shopping
around trying to garner that information
you can offer that service or you hope
to we can offer bits of that service now
if you need like a survey on your on
your parish hall for solar and ev
we can do that right now as long as you
have this legal vehicle that we can help
but if the things you say
i want to know i want this information
because it helps me to achieve this goal
and we don't know where it is or we need
to design something to do it then that's
again something we can do but i also
think part of the problem is i might not
necessarily know
what i don't know so i know you're tell
me what i don't know and what i should
know and what i need to be looking at so
so
i didn't want to go go here but but part
of our part of our project
is because we've we've been set up
because
uh
most sorry a lot of
in this country we're heavily focused on
new technology
virtually all of our budget and actually
across the world over the last
50 years or whatever
of all
this there's the problems of technology
and there's the problems of how we
deploy that technology the social
context in which we do it our governance
our councils with the rest of it
less than 0.1 of all the research on
climate change has gone into the how do
we deliver this stuff
all of the rest has gone into technology
and sent sensors and all the rest of it
and which is crazy because most of the
problems that we're going to have in the
next 30 years our social problems our
governance problems it's it's how do we
do this how do we change this
infrastructure we're living in while
we're all living in it to a completely
new technology
it's it's a really difficult it's a
really difficult challenge
and we've spent very little time
thinking about it
but yeah to build on what alex said i
think that
there is a lot of expertise within our
partnership within eastern eu energy
we've
got lots of partners with expertise in
lots of different sectors who've helped
lots of different types of organizations
who
would be able to
perhaps look at a plan and say well
yeah this looks great but have you
considered this other thing so there
might be an element of yeah we can
advise on things that you don't know
about if if that expertise sits within
our partnership and partnership with
broad and there's a lot of expertise
there so
yeah there's there's some of that that
we can do
so yeah just a step back in the
partnership we've got energy project
development
construction
retrofit
electric vehicles data we have expertise
in all of those areas and more
can i just question that then just a bit
as we talk about what works well
and then they'll give us an idea you
know how we can get to these
unknown unknowns kind of thing but this
will really worked well for
in my opinion was uh the
um the joint procurement approach that
was done for the solar panels
that was a solution which was just
they're ready to be picked up and it was
advertised to people there's some
knowledge on it i think there's a lot of
stuff that's perhaps being done in the
background we just don't know about it
so
you know the next big
big challenge we're going to have is
retrofit we heard a bit about that this
morning
glenn was talking about
listed buildings and so on i think a
package
which says if you're tackling retrofits
everybody's going to be doing it in a
major way
the steps you need to take on this this
and this and this is the training
program that we put in place for for
info pack we put in place for
conservation officers
we're equally going to be
uh an endangered species so i can
imagine quite quickly if
we don't find a positive way to work
together
where we're taking the parish
and we're we're going to be going house
white house business by business farm by
farm to do a plan for each
then
we don't know how much it's going to
cost today we haven't
it's lovely it was there was a pre-pilot
in the sussex a couple of years ago it's
called community yes because we're
having to learn how to do all those
things
and
what
what we're trying to do here is is ask
questions and learn with you
because who likes things really done to
them and have imposed upon them very few
people enjoy having things imposed upon
i'm one of those people so
it's we're trying to collaboratively
work out what we need and help to create
that rather than rather than
sitting
based in central government
who who they are sat there thinking how
do we make councils do things how do we
make
parishes although they're not even
thinking about parishes
so that's that's what we're trying to do
is
is do things in a different way and work
with the people who are going to be
affected to try and design it together
that's the plan
i don't know if that gets wide support
that the retrofit is a priority
i mean
you suggested that we just
put that on the agenda would you want to
transform something really happy either
way
well my parishes problem is
almost quite the opposite
um
how do we stop people building
we are
a very small parish covering a very
large area so very
and that a lot of that area is open
common land
um
and what is the common land is
agricultural then so it's a huge lum
in our part of the county
and
we have
developers
who
are
lining their pockets
building totally inappropriate
mansions
that are bought up by people from essex
and london at
inordinate prices
so our poor local children
cannot afford to buy
they opt out of their
promise to include affordable houses
um and we don't need them we don't need
the houses we don't need the people
actually
um
because we need the lungs we need the
air we need the space and so does all
the communities right
that's there's a lot a lot of different
threats in
in that
in that particular story um
that it just occurred to me and i
haven't thought of it before is that
some parishes may opt or decide they
want to opt to be
rewired in areas or mainly rewilding
areas and their contribution to
to the whole
is a very different one to a local
authority to a parish that maybe
is quite happy to host a large solar
panel maybe there's a
trade-off or a connection between them
where
everything everything that we need is
achieved but in different places by
negotiations
what we've got are not incompatible
they're not incompatible it's these
wretched houses
they are the problem because they're
because they're
they're changing the whole nature and
they're excluding
young people and people on lower incomes
and i i don't know how about my feelings
oh is this just
kind of feeds into the local planning
frameworks as well the planning policies
and
part of the problem is around giving
people who are making decisions around
planning applications knowledge of what
their powers are and what they can what
restrictions they can put on those
developers to say actually no you need
to go away and rethink this development
because it doesn't fit with our vision
for the for the community but that and
that that's a that's a another issue
of
um
how are they getting this
of what you're saying there and i think
that
you know
perhaps through neighborhood planning um
you can try and protect areas of green
space and there may be
some legislation around
open space that can help you to protect
things like common land and maybe maybe
implement or create by-laws around
planning on common land as well
um
so there's in place that's definitely
yes spaces
but perhaps it's not development per se
that's the problem but the type of
development and the character of that
development and i think that's where
neighbourhood planning
can be a benefit if you want to protect
the green space so i just was like
that's a really interesting point i
think the way we approached it in a
parish in cornwall is is
it's it's one village with a with a
housing waiting list of 240
families
it's an insane parish
in many ways and they've decided to take
control of the process because there are
big levelers coming into as you say
build form five bedroom houses for
people who live a long way away from
blood whereas the people who need the
houses need one and two bedroom
places and they're very low local those
level people are driven further away
specifically to a big field with loads
of caravans on it which is
which is
better but the um
what what they're trying to do is take
control of the process partly through
the neighborhood plan and because
they've got their own very detailed
assessments of housing need which are
more detailed than the ones that mhclg
in homes england and the council needs
they know exactly what they need and
they're going to develop their own
housing to meet the needs they're taking
control of that process and by
controlling that process
they drive out all of the other
developers because the other developers
can't provide any evidence of housing
need
so i think there are
approaches
that can be explored to to potentially
help your parish achieve get closer to
what it wants
so
just i was just thinking about listening
to this i mean you're talking about
needing to increase biodiversity and
increase
carbon absorption in the future and it
occurs to me that green open spaces are
exactly what do that and that needs to
become far more valuable and that will
make a difference the way in which
planning happens
the in the near-ish future in the next
few decades in other words
large-scale building development for
very very low density is presumably just
not going to be on because it is no
longer sustainable and the green space
is in any case much better used for
biodiversity
and curb and absorption i i think we're
fairly unimaginative in this country
about how we solve problems and so for
example in wales they've got the one
planet development act the well-being of
future generations act and some of the
developments that are emerging in wales
is they will only allow you to build
if you're 50
self-sufficient and basically carbon
neutral across the whole development so
there's a very specific sorts of
developments but because
of of and people have to evidence that
they prove
they meet those standards an ongoing
basis they're allowing
all sorts of different development and
and different groups are coming up with
different solutions to that so they've
enabled a very innovative
approach and people and we're
now got a number of developments in
wales that we can study and go okay this
is actually very it is a biodiversity
positive development that meets the
housing needs of
the local community and so on and so
forth so i think that we're very used to
this country to the model of a developer
comes in a commercial developer comes in
pushes the boundaries of what
they can achieve make as much money as
they can extract that money go off and
do it somewhere else there are different
models but we need to be organized
local communities and groups need to be
organized in order to take it
to deliver that
sorry
just just about what you're saying and
perhaps some people agree perhaps people
will
not agree but i also think that
in the uk we have to sort of um
start thinking about the european sort
of style of development
perhaps gentle identification
that we made because of living in sort
of high density
um areas um
rather than
sort of
large houses with big back gardens and
things because if we were doing this
then we would be able to
more easily sort
lay public transport infrastructure
and and to be able to
reduce the the footprints in which
development is taking up and we'll be
able to assign more of that green space
but um
i kind of i wonder if i can take
the conversation on a slightly different
direction um if
now where i'm coming from as a district
councillor in this meeting is i'm trying
to persuade three parish councils
to
to
to vote for or just i would say to to
declare a climate change emergency
and
the parish councils come back to me with
the very same question every time
what can we do as a parish council
to make a difference now i'm probably
several steps behind everyone else in
the room here although i've heard some
very good ideas already in other other
sessions and in this meeting but what do
you personally think
perhaps are the top three or five things
that
a parish of around 500 to 1000
residents
could do
very effectively and importantly without
a huge level of cost
well
i suppose i've responded it depends
who's paying the cost
because i think that like the mod the
housing model with with looking at in
cornwall
the community aren't
paying it
triodos bank will probably fund it
and then and then as the rents over 25
years will pay for it and then those are
that's community wealth community assets
no money's changing handlings at that
local level
what are the one of the things
it really depends from parish to parish
in my limited experience
but
but
i suppose declaring a climate emergency
getting a neighborhood plan in place
bringing everyone together
because they're again experiencing
some some parishes and communities are
very separate whereas some are very very
close together it just varies from place
to place
i think i think
yes and also coordinated with districts
and counties so you've got the back up
and that that's that's more i believe
on the districts and the counties that
are better resourced and they're very
underresourced but it's a better
resource
and we're talking with essex county
council are
looking at how we do that how they sort
of align and gain us but there's 53
parishes we're going to bring them all
together with the district and the
county and try to align
we've done a big data map of the whole
of the district and we're going to be
looking at energy projects we're going
to be looking at housing projects we're
going to be looking at bb infrastructure
and and we're trying to get everyone in
the room who needs to be there to take
the decision so it's not something taken
by a private developer or county or
district it's everyone's in the room and
we collectively decide
how
we do this the other thing with energy
and carbon of course these are complex
big systems
it's really hard to work on them as
individual projects
um
it's much better to think about them at
a larger scale
sorry there's somebody there's somebody
behind just building on that question
really about what to do
as a parish council that has a robust
neighborhood development
that has identified many areas in our
village improvement
and the debate that we're having is
concentrate on one
project
or to be straight thinly across is there
a logistical
you know which is better do you think
okay we if we've got eight and a half
years to reduce emissions by 45
i don't think we can
do things in sequence we've got to start
looking at doing things in parallel
and that's part of
why we want to work with a group of
councils to figure out what
what the barriers are what we can do to
remove them
how we support parishes when i say
really i mean collectively figuring out
what we need
developing and putting into place
i think the other the other side sorry
is that one thing to look at is to
assess all of these different ideas that
you have in terms of what will their
impact be
and try to pick as i said it's good to
work on these things in parallel um
but maybe pick the the two or three that
have the biggest impact
um and focus
75 of your efforts there and then 25
percent of your efforts
on
of keeping all of the other projects in
the background taking over and trying to
progress the other thing is i would say
kind of combining those two points is
don't underestimate
the level of influence that you can have
and how much impact that influence can
have further down the line so although
there may be things that parishes do not
control directly you probably have more
a lot of influence
um to
to change behavior in other people or or
other
county council this morning exactly that
point was made and if a number of
parishes can come together and talk to
the and talk to the council and say we
want this we need this that makes it a
lot easier for the officers in the
council
to get those resources to help
so there's so many hands up now i've
lost track of them
we have
declared a climate emergency we have a
robust local plan
we have numerous plans we've just taken
on from woodland we're trying to take on
all the district council land in the
parish
hopefully we'll get that
but we don't know where we actually
stand
we don't know what our
carbon emission was when we started
we don't know where how much we've got
to reduce to get it to where we need it
to be
we need
somebody to come in an order to say well
this is how much you as the parish
council need to lose and this is what
the village needs to lose and if you can
work towards both of those at the same
time
we can definitely help you with that
good but we have never uploaded
[Music]
one of the problems is lots of different
agencies and
well you just suggested the point about
everyone reinventing the wheel so we've
also got sarah gill of ground works yes
she came and did a
set up a survey for us at homesleep
so that we could have orders of
um carbon emissions and
how great the problem was how helpful
that is i don't know it is a starting
point
yes sometimes it's useful to have a
baseline and sometimes it's more
important to just act it's just an
obvious thing yes it's an emergency
exactly and we're not treating it as an
emergency
well we're really waiting through
treacle we
mutual housing from new housing from
2016 on okay for a government that'd
been done the uh building rigs of that
time i can
definitely tell you that solving the
problem of central government it's
outside of the state
because that's where emergency comes
from where's the 50 mile an hour speed
limit we had it back in
in 1976 when there was a trivial oil
emergency now there's an existential oil
emergency
yeah there's no end to things it is
outside our scope but we are wading
through tree core yeah
sorry lots of them
i i think to the district council's
asking questions
and
parishes uh even smaller it's 370
individuals just to give you a few i
mean i don't know what level you're
looking at but as a parish council we
have
switched to a renewable energy supply
which has slashed our electricity prices
we've had led lighting put in we've
expanded our
recycling point which is generating
income for us as a parish
and then next month we're having our
sustainable cramston meeting where we've
got a list of things from
recycle more through to generating
community energy through to lobbying at
local national and international level
just as ideas to say these are the
practical things that as a community or
as an individual you can be doing
because there's a lot of talk and what
we actually need is people doing stuff
and so that's what we're trying to
promote and it might be of interest to
your soul
that's fantastic and to add to that uh
two and a half years ago i estimated the
carbon footprint of the village it's not
difficult it's about everything online
so 135 houses 2 000 tonnes 14 tons of
the house and then you can start
breaking that down where it's coming
from oil or heating or lighting or
whatever and you can start to say where
it's going but what i'd like to ask you
is your project targeted at making a
parish what well it sounds like to me
you you look worthless um
we want to see
every parish becoming net zero yes but
this are you going to be working with
every aspect of everybody's life to get
there because
that's it
that's a fantastic question
and business within that parish oh yes i
think businesses and farms are
crucial because they're tons of
attention
um i
i think this is one of these things
where we need to do it
to find out what works for us so what
you've actually got to do is um actually
re-localize virtually every service that
a human consumes
so we currently have a centralized food
system that is not fit for purpose
has so many externalities that are
unseen is untrue a wall of plastic in
every supermarket is not a
fit service for this country and so it's
a problem for the most of the world
actually the western world of western
economic development will become this
rust which is actually a trap
and just to let you understand my
perspective
i'm a farm manager on a large animal
farm i'm currently
the county chair for the national
farmers union
and i've done my transition training
some 20 years ago with transition terms
etc i'm a member of green greenpeace i'm
a member of friends of the earth and
i've been watching it for too many years
and realized that actually we this is
one heck of a significant problem that
we have so so
a number of other people have sent
similar guns to us
and one of one of the one of them
one of the things we're doing in suffolk
with the university and the council and
the technical commissioning groups is
setting up a data trust and the purpose
of the data trust is to bring together
all of the data
of the county that is relevant to
decarbonisation and and biodiversity all
the rest of it and start enabling the
private data and the public data to be
put together in a way that all of us as
citizens businesses parishes whoever can
use it to take better functioning
so how many mutes are in my pond and
barn owls fly are not going to be
significant arguably they are
they need to be the positive result at
the end of it but they don't need to
know that at the moment now that
probably that data is yeah
sense sensing and capturing that data is
probably a long way down the road
but the um
the point is local food systems
are things that you can begin to take
action you can relocalize consumption
and production if you know where the
food is what the data flows and if you
can aggregate demand through charities
to individuals to business to steer that
demand towards different ways of doing
things so that's not an
example
um ten years ago this country had eleven
under we're gonna eat meat a lot in the
future it's another matter which we have
to understand some will reduce it but i
don't think that but
ten years ago it never
in this country which meant that when
with a bit of plug you had somewhere
local to take your animals that met the
food the food chain for us as humans now
we're down to 200 they are centralized
uh economic monsters and they have to
run on high output and highly high input
and high output to actually serve the
system that we have so
i would suggest that whatever energy it
is that a human requires whether it's
food or
electrical or hydrogen or whatever else
they all have to be relocalized
tremendously and i think i think the
work of the world of data and analytics
and algorithms i don't need any data to
work out really
i i think that he's got potential to do
that
information
allows people to take decisions always
measuring is taking far too long
there is a problem here surely i mean
localization sounds terrific
but it's extremely inefficient go back
200 years and you'll find that um most
farms have a mixed enterprise they had
cattle sheep pigs
and all of those products actually went
to local people and now unfortunately
have a large urban society now which is
very difficult it actually means that
the surface from the areas that can work
that should be producing locally the
surface of that should then move in as
energy efficient way
and something like that's going to
happen when today the people talking
later about the changes that are needed
and they cannot be seen they are so
radical
they probably cannot so what what we do
have the scope to look at
is is is to start saying okay so this is
one
one parish one's found in your role with
the nfv very interesting a lot of work
with you in the past
um they don't agree with me all the time
it's very hard they're normally about 10
years behind
this is frightening but but the the
point is we can
for example um
say okay this is this is an interesting
this is one parish that wants to look in
depth maybe with a couple of other
parishes nearby and explore what
relocalization looks like and that would
probably
given how government funding works it
would start as a model but i wouldn't
say it didn't turn into a demonstration
yeah
absolutely i think there are some
calculators um for the nfu climate
change by the centers of stuff earlier
this year
and actually what i'm looking at how
should you provide what area of land it
takes to divide the staples say for a
community of a thousand people and then
you didn't sail it up or down you know
in your local
area and you could see how then we would
actually create
a diverse landscape because
everyone talks about the diversity loss
it's because of modern cultures so we
ought to have a diverse food production
system um enabled to change i think
i would love to continue this
conversation yeah yeah
okay
can i take us a little bit different
direction now but we're at a time
and you talk about what it was we need
some help with or whatever and
you know typically in the example for us
we're in buildings and we're trying to
do a district heating system for the
village it's quite compact compact image
so we think the centralized heat source
our soft and fire may be a good solution
for us um and the people we are getting
who are volunteering to help us to work
with this and it's gonna be a very
interesting project i think following
this through
tend to be older retired folk or
whatever
is there some some ideas or if you've
done some thinking about getting us
access to younger people
to come in and to
follow that
transition that we're doing
i think some
some of those perspectives into the
program would then give a generation
come out because once we're finished i
think the people are doing it can be
finished
are you saying you want some heat
network consultancy too no consultancy
is not a problem because we can get that
through the feasibility study grants and
so on and so forth
you know real
young
people who would follow that project
through and then could use that as a
stepping stone to develop their own
career path essentially rather than just
handing the money to consultants uh
externally so the university of support
we're posting to the university suffolk
so and uh i think the college as well
is part of this
i see no reason why if if
you were doing that we couldn't try and
attach an apprentice case study or
something exactly
but again and of course anything that we
do
might be an opportunity for students and
apprentices to
come and work with you and support you
and they learn they learn how to work
together they learn about real problems
on the ground they
learn they
i mean there are some things where
there are some programs where work
experience would make sense but i'm i'm
not i think a lot of the things that
we're talking about here are quite early
stage trying to work out what it is you
need rather than delivering what you
need
the work experience is itself a learning
experience
i think that's something
we've not been able to address because
you know it is to a certain extent it is
a country
i can put it that way and uh we are not
you know over-endowed with young people
but i can just i can uh reach into the
community particularly who have already
expressed an interest in working on
something like this like imagine as a
young student i would have been
animated
and motivated to take part in something
like this if and i could take a large
amount of responsibility early on i
think this is
25 years out there who are just thinking
there's no other game in town i want to
be working in decarbonisation
because there's no point in being
anything else
well i think it's part of our job to the
university to try and surface them and
see if we can broker some kind of
mutually beneficial support
yeah we're talking about
major major areas that we obviously are
common amongst all of us i still think
that probably transport is going to be
the biggest one we talked about the fact
that
it is the the biggest contributor to
carbon
issues even if we get we move towards
electric vehicles we're still going to
have all the waste from the wear of
tyres and microplastic to come out of
that type of thing
so where are we going to look at trying
to come up with an organized policy
because
we as a part of we've become so much
encouraged in our in our areas to
actually use your own goal all the time
because of transport traffic public
transport
it's a
22 situation that public transport
doesn't get supplied because it isn't
profitable to run it
but it isn't proper to run it until you
actually got people who think that it's
better to use that than to use your own
vehicle we all have to have to be here
today yeah yeah
and
and
i think that's a particularly difficult
problem
as much as anything is a magazine
yeah i think i think from a parish
perspective
that's probably one of the hardest
problems to crack you know active travel
planning and
you know we're talking is to put a cycle
infrastructure networking placement for
30 years but it's an interesting one
because the in east suffolk
every single one of their community
partnerships has put transport as one of
the top three issues
and yeah i must admit i think that's one
of the
hardest things that we might look at i'm
kind of conscious that we've we've been
asked to go back in about 10 minutes
um i'm i'm
can i just ask what links you have with
song
and
i'm very
concerned about
the relationship with the light between
sarc
and the parish councils
southwark association
and it's for me it's um
i'm looking at because i'm terrible with
your scrutiny i'm looking at whether
that is valuable money or counsels
whether you feel that they feel that
they get they found
why is the district council actually
asking about
whether value for money being members of
salkis
because i am concerned about support but
that but i'm sorry that's not really a
district council
membership i guess sorry that that's
we're getting slightly off the top yeah
while we're here can i just say that
this
that our project
is emerged from itself from from south
so everything that we do and the funding
that we bring support to
to parishes and we do over the next year
and a half that has been enabled and
that comes from sale so what then can i
ask then what
information and communication
around this subject
has been distributed to parish councils
uh nothing yet because this is the first
meeting
because that's what we're looking at i
think that's what i think
i
you can't actually
go back to the district councils from
whence you you stem ultimately until
they get a suitable vehicle a
charity or a community company
no so to support a parish we do need a
the parish must have a
legal vehicle yes yes so that was my
point although
you came from the pure parish councils
who sold you can't actually go back to
the parish council per se
we hope that any of the work we do
will provide benefit for all yes okay
sorry
in establishing a legal vehicle or
charity or cic or whatever it may be
um can parish councils
um merge to form this so can that
can that charity or that organization be
composed of multiple parish councils so
rather than having all these very
individual organizations for each parish
council can five parish councils or
however many
join up basically to to establish this
organization yes but it makes our life
much harder really yeah okay so sorry i
i wasn't getting it through that
congress without that so so
rooting to this legacy eu money yeah so
just just to be clear we've funded
through the european regional
development program
you're a research project right and the
reason the reason it's taken so long to
be where we are is we were proposing to
do very different things to typical
research projects and look and look at
problems in a very different way and it
took a long time for the project to be
improved which is why we're so late in
delivering it
so
i don't
i don't
who want to be part of this whether
you've got a specific project
that we can support and do a survey for
or you want to help us
work with us to design the things that
parishes need
so
um we
hopefully you don't mind us emailing you
or contacting you from the
this year i'd like to join you brilliant
[Music]
they're in a position to
open up a field of communication between
different parishes to form these and
informal groups of people
so
i'm a
town councilman and a clerk in a couple
of small parishes and just
just in defense of south carolina
they have set up a number of um recently
webinars open to all parishes to join
and out of that and i i took part in
that and after that there was a sort of
informal network of parishes that are
interested in climate change issues that
are on aim and
yeah so
facilitating quite a lot of learning
that's going on so um
i'm grateful to learn together as as i'm
equivalent in essex and norfolk who are
also talking with them
sorry have you got enough people that
you can um attend a big meeting if we
arrange a meeting between a couple of
parishes of parish councils
um village associations virtual people
that sort of thing have you got
i you are able to come and attend and
give a
talk about this i would have thought so
yes
i would don't want to confirm for
definitely right now by this magical
principle yes
do you think that ought to be the first
meeting of this kind or do you think we
should have one first
i do what put the feelers out
i think what what
um our bosses would prefer is we have
everyone who's interested we have a
one-to-one discussion with them online
and then we just get a little bit more
information on you check eligibility all
the rest of it
and then once we've
then once we've got 10 or more parishes
that want to be part of this
then we all get together whether it's
online or in real life depending on
everything else
and by having those one-to-one
discussions first we can spot where the
parallels are between the parishes and
perhaps put three or four together
interested in the same thing and then
another three or four very interested in
something different so we can spot those
links start to make them
so if you're having ten parishes
together you wouldn't be able to discuss
individual things much would you well i
think the plan is if we if we
if we talk to town i mean in in an ideal
world we might talk to 30
but then we we
parishes that are interested in the same
things we can have discussion on themes
so if it's neighborhood planning we
might have a discussion on neighborhood
planning if it's
developing your own housing around the
housing
so
[Music]
all or
we do whatever suits everyone
and maybe it maybe it is the case we all
get together in a big room and talk
we're
flexible here
to whatever you
think is the best way of doing it
we've got to do our bit on our side but
making it easy for you as part of that
so for those of us who are interested in
working with you
how how are you going to start that how
can we have your contact details
will you guys have you
yeah
either go just south
or if you if you've got your names on
those sheets yeah we're gonna i know we
can ask for emails on issues but we can
get the emails
so so just email everyone and say right
here just a little bit more information
on us